[Aplausos]
bueno pues hoy están aquí para escuchar
ideas dignas de difundir y pues por eso
me pidieron que ya de una vez saliera
de lo que todos están pensando se deben
estar preguntando de qué nos va a hablar
este señor extremadamente apuesto y
distinguido
yo también me lo pregunta así que no
tiene nada de qué preocuparse viendo
tantas caras jóvenes como la mía me
hacen recordar una anécdota con mis
alumnos cuando me enteré que me
convertiría en orador ellos fueron los
primeros a los que les compartí la idea
al igual que ellos se emocionaron y
recuerdo como rápidamente una alumna
levanta la mano y me dice profe
las charlas sex son esas en donde
comparten ideas muy creativas muy
innovadoras que nos motivan y nos
inspiran mucho si le responde y profe
antes de terminar
también es donde salen personas muy
inteligentes con mucha experiencia vaya
muy cultas
y le respondí así es y antes de
finalizar me me pregunta el nuevo profe
y sabiendo todo esto aún así que
participará usted
hoy por razones que desconozco es alumna
ya no estudia en la universidad
el from a todos pues debe por andar por
ahí
muy bien bueno hace muchos años la
verdad no son tantos para que esté
escuchar lo impactante inicia este
camino de la educación
al principio como cualquier otro
comienzo la verdad tenía muchas dudas
tenía muchas desconfianzas porque por un
lado tenía la idea de transmitir la
mayor cantidad de información a mis
alumnos con el fin de que pues no
existiera ningún campo a ninguna duda
pero por el otro lado tenía el objetivo
firme de compartir la pasión por
aprender
en este momento quiero que me ayuden
ustedes con una actividad quiero que
piensen en el nombre de un profesor que
creen que su labor al educarlos fue muy
mala
ya lo tienen sé muy bien uno de esos
profesores que todos los días antes de
irnos a la escuela decíamos entonces
hablamos aquí diosito ya llévatelo
ya vivió no y por otro lado si les
pregunto que piensen en el nombre de un
profesor que su laboral educarlos crean
que haya sido muy buena
piensen
estoy seguro y no me dejarán mentir que
fue mucho más fácil identificarlo saben
por qué porque fue un profesor que logró
crear una relación efectiva con ustedes
logró vincularse de manera positiva con
sus emociones
tomando precisamente esto en cuenta
durante mi desarrollo como maestro me
hizo una pregunta esa pregunta fue si yo
en mi labor
quería educar como siempre o educar como
nunca y precisamente para dar respuesta
a esa pregunta
supe que tenía que hacer frente al
desafío de educar mentes y conectar
corazones y que para hacerlo debía de
asumir la responsabilidad de hacer la
diferencia de romper reglas y estándares
para poder conquistar los cada vez que
yo me encuentro con un nuevo grupo trato
inspirarlos desde el principio que los
conozco no entonces yo entro por primera
vez al salón fotos con la expectativa de
que bueno un nuevo profesor se me paró
al frente y les digo hoy están aquí y
están por adentrarse a la aventura de
sus vidas
aún sin merecer me estoy aquí frente a
ustedes para tostar los del conocimiento
de sabiduría para convertirlos en la
mejor versión de sí mismos cuando entré
por esa puerta serán unos y les aseguro
que cuando salgan por ella serán otros
distintos superiores no tendrán que
agradecerme lo sólo vayan y hagan de
éste un mundo mejor
obvio no me lo cree
e incluso se me quedan viendo ha sido
como de qué está hablando este señor no
pero sé que dentro de ellos se plantaba
una semilla que al irse a regando no con
agua sino con pasión valor inspiración
irá creciendo y en un tiempo va a dar
dulces frutos y esa es una de las
mayores satisfacción que se pueden
encontrar en la labor de educar
trato de que mis clases sean toda una
experiencia no refiriéndome a la idea en
que yo como profesor pues me voy a tener
que convertir en el mejor amigo de todos
mis alumnos no
tampoco con la idea en que tengo que
convertirme en una especie de payasito
ya saben y los tengo que estar
entretenida de hacerlos reír
constantemente no me refiero a
motivarlos
a devolver la pasión de aprender en el
aula a enseñarles que no es una
obligación sino el camino que los
llevará a construir un mundo mejor no
solamente para ellos sino también para
los que lo rodean y además le voy a
asumir el compromiso de que mi labor
tendrá un eco para toda la vida de mis
estudiantes
educar realmente es una tarea de la que
sigo aprendiendo más aún cuando mis
alumnos todos los días no dejan de
sorprenderme recuerdo que me encontraba
en una clase
y yo estaba así con todo el power esté
explicando lo que era el pensamiento
creativo entonces en una de estas clases
antes de finalizar les pedí como
actividad de reforzamiento que pensar en
una situación en particular en donde
hubieran utilizado su creatividad para
resolver un problema entonces recuerdo
como rápidamente una alumna no la que
corrimos otra otra alumna me levanto
rápidamente la mano y me dice cómo comer
barbacoa cuando cuando en lugar de
cuchara te dan un tenedor
así me quedé con esa misma cara que tú
dices
y recuerdo que con curiosidad le
respondí así bueno pues sí como lo
resolví este y me dice pues bueno tomé
un trozo de tortilla la convertí en una
cuchara entonces ahora tengo la tortilla
para el jugo y tengo el tenedor para la
carne eso es pensamiento creativo
aún con la sorpresa en mi rostro la
verdad es que entendí que este camino al
que le llamo educación en este viaje se
vuelve aún más enriquecedor cuando mis
alumnos me enseñan lo que traen en su
maleta y eso es su manera única de mirar
el mundo y que muchas veces aunque no
son las respuestas que esperamos no
sobre todo este de mi alumna que cuando
me respondió me quedé viendo así como
que bueno esta niña nomás no le sube
agua al tinaco
pero entendí y ella me demostró que aún
con esa sorpresa y al no esperarme esa
esa respuesta a parte de ella me dio
evidencia de que está encendiendo la luz
de su inteligencia no bueno durante mi
educación yo aprendí de una manera
distinta a la de mis profesores y ahora
de mis maestros y de igual manera hoy en
día mis alumnos están aprendiendo de una
manera totalmente distinta a la mía y
ustedes se preguntarán por qué pues eso
se debe a que los desafíos que habrán de
enfrentarse hoy en día mis estudiantes y
los estudiantes que se encuentran aquí
son totalmente distintos a los nuestros
a los que nosotros vivimos en nuestra
época es por eso que en los últimos años
hay un sinfín de cambios y de ajustes en
las teorías y en las metodologías del
aprendizaje
y eso es algo que ha venido a brindar
muchos aspectos positivos en la
educación sin embargo lo más importante
en educación siempre se centrará en el
vínculo que se genera entre el profesor
y el alumno
la verdad es que esto educar no resulta
a veces nada fácil aún dando lo mejor de
mí me he encontrado con alumnos que
realmente ni se emocionan con la manera
en la que los quiero educar alumnos que
no lo aceptan de la misma manera
y de igual manera yo como profesor no me
resulta tan fácil trabajar con ellos me
he encontrado con alumnos
me encontraba con alumnos
ésta se escucha muy bien me he contado
con alumnos ya la visita les decimos
para que aprendas casa con barreras tan
difíciles de penetrar alumnos que no me
han caído enteramente bien y otros que
me han sacado canas verdes bueno incluso
alopecia
pero aún con todo esto trato de siempre
motivarlos no de devolver el placer de
aprender a las aulas de hacerles saber y
enseñarles que no es una obligación sino
el camino que los conducirá a crear un
mundo mejor no solamente para ellos sino
también para todos los que lo rodean la
verdad es que cuando veo sus rostros aún
y con todo esto que les digo que me
sacan las caras verdes que me ponen a
veces de malas a veces que no logro
compaginar con ellos no logro ser
compatibles porque cada uno de ellos
tienen su propia esencia
no sé qué hay detrás
yo no sé cuáles son las batallas
internas y sus luchas por las que cada
quien está pasando es por eso que si
bien he entendido que no puedo cambiar
su mundo por completo trataré en mi
clase de hacer todo lo posible para no
solamente de darles un espejo para que
reflejen su realidad sino también de un
martillo para que logren darle forma
entendiendo que motivar es convertir
algo común en algo extraordinario
además asumir el compromiso de que yo
como profesor debo de buscar que mi
alumno siempre aprenda a brillar aún en
momentos de obscuridad
uno de los libros que más han
influenciado mi vida personal y ahora
profesional es el principito
lo conocen
bueno pues este cuento nos enseña el
valor de las cosas más importantes de
esta vida como son la generosidad la
bondad la tolerancia y el amor y el
poder que tienen para convertirnos en
mejores seres humanos dentro de él su
autor
antoine de saint exupéry escribió una de
las frases que más han dejado huella en
mí
solo con el corazón se puede ver bien lo
esencial es invisible a los ojos
dar y recibir amor es una decisión y yo
decido querer a mis alumnos
bueno al menos intentarlo porque sé que
haciéndolo habría alcanzado lo que yo
considero es el éxito en mi labor como
maestro
y eso es que alguien se convirtió en una
mejor versión de sí mismo o logro
construir un mundo mejor
y esa es una de las mayores
satisfacciones
que puedo encontrar
y con la que puedo asegurar que hice un
cambio
por no haber existido coincidido y
tocado sus vidas
todos mis alumnos que se han cruzado
conmigo en mis clases creían que sólo
iba a enseñarles cuando realmente era yo
el que aprendía de ellos
todos los maestros que nos encontrábamos
en esta labor de educar hagámoslo en
grande continuemos ayudando a nuestros
alumnos a construir sus propias salas ya
enseñarnos a volar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]